her mother and father have been
convicted of murdering their baby son
just weeks after he was placed back in
their care ten month old Finley Bowden
died on Christmas day of 2020. Derby
Crown Court heard his parents Stephen
Bowden and Shannon Marsden subjected
Finley to repeated acts of severe
violence in the days before his death
let's bring in our correspondent Melena
vasilanovic who's in The Newsroom Milena
this is absolutely horrific what do we
know it's an extremely upsetting case
his his parents are 10 month old
Finley's parents have been convicted of
his murder after a five-week trial at
Derby Crown called the court heard that
the little boy suffered extensive
injuries 71 bruises across his entire
body 57 fractures but also Burns that
were consistent with someone holding
lighter fluid lighter flame close to his
small body and this happened only 39
days after he was placed back into the
care of his parents now the court heard
that 10 month old Finley collapsed in
the family home after suffering a
cardiac arrest on Christmas Day in 2020
a home that was described in court as
filthy as crammed the police also said
that there were feces found in the
bedroom now the boy's father Stephen
Bowden tried to blame the family's dog
on some of the injuries experienced by
his son saying the dog may have jumped
on the boy causing
some ribs to be broken that was
dismissed in court we also heard about a
text message in which Stephen Bode and
the boy's father had claimed that he
wanted to see Finley bounce off the
walls now extremely upsetting details
and now the court also heard that
Marsden the boy's mother had later said
after his death that his dad had
battered him and that she had failed to
protect him now what is particularly
upsetting about this case is that we
know that 10 month old Finley was
removed from his parents care shortly
after being born in February of 2020
because there were concerns for his
welfare however he was returned to his
parents by a court order over an
eight-week transition period even though
the social workers were asking for a
six-month transition period so three
times as long and now questions will be
asked as to why this happened and why
this small vulnerable baby was returned
to the hands of the people who although
they were his parents were the ones who
eventually killed him
Milena thank you
a U.S serviceman is expected to appear
in court today accused of leaking highly
classified military documents Jack
teshera was arrested by the FBI at his
home in Massachusetts yesterday and is
set to be charged under the Espionage
Act